oh boy this episode is gonna cause a lot
of controversy yes american horror
stories season one has come to an end
with its final episode game over for
those of you who don't know ah stories
has been renewed for season two but some
are calling for it to be cancelled after
this latest episode i'll get to all that
and the dozens of ahs easter eggs and
there are a lot in this video and be
sure to like and subscribe because
starting next week we have a brand new
season of american horror story which
i'll be covering if you haven't checked
out my full trailer breakdown with
theories on the upcoming season i'll
leave a link to it in the description
below but for now let's return a murder
house for the 1000th time hey i know
that place well it looks like michael
and troy's plan to turn murderhouse into
a haunted bnb experience has come to
fruition remember they were scarlett's
parents from the first two episodes of
the season who were looking to
capitalize on the home's low value to
turn it into a haunted experience and
the episode gets off to a truly
terrifying start as we're introduced to
miley cyrus's younger sister noah cyrus
she plays connie alongside boyfriend
dylan who are self-proclaimed hs
fanatics looking to spend a night in one
of america's most haunted houses the two
even mentioned the lary mansion in new
orleans which can be seen in season
three's coven there is even a slight nod
to the hotel cortez the driver describes
the house as the devil's [ __ ] as it
is the place where the devil michael
langdon was born as well as the house
itself being born on top of a hellmouth
also known as an entrance to hell but
this couple doesn't really care and go
off about how they dressed up as the son
of bloodyface and sister jude both of
whom were characters seen in season 2's
asylum inside connie gets a vision of
the rubber man i won't get into too much
detail about him as i covered him in my
episode 1 and 2 breakdown but needless
to say he plays a big role in season 1
and even has a few cameos in season 8's
apocalypse in the kitchen they're
greeted with some wine black rose petals
and a card that says welcome to murder
house which is also the title of the
very first episode of american horror
story connie reads the back of the note
referring to violetators which is a
mashup of the names violet and tate who
are lovers in season one they head on
upstairs to what was once tate langdon
and violet's room dylan even puts on the
iconic tate langdon sweater to get
connie in the mood but ends up lasting
as long as one of my relationships they
notice that all these candles have been
lit and surmise that someone must be in
the house to facilitate the scares they
even joke it could be larry harvey
dennis o'hare's character from season 1
who burned his family alive in murder
house we hear adelaide langdon's voice
call out you're going to die and hear
one of her iconic lines from season 1 as
well as beau langdon's red ball roll in
something we also saw in episode 1 of
this season yet we never see beau they
find the body of nurse gladys a murdered
character from season 1 who also makes
an appearance in the first two episodes
of stories but they believe this all to
be a part of the horror experience they
even remark how it must have been serial
killer richard speck who killed the
nurse which is a callback to the
character he inspired in season 1 r
franklin who killed nurses after a
thermometer broke in his mouth and this
is where we get our first glimpse of the
season-going meta which some have
criticized connie's character says of
season five's roanoke why does sarah
paulson should talk this season the show
has now become a commentary unto itself
this is later expanded upon by the
character of rory who talks about how
he's an hs super fan and only super fans
understand what american horror story is
some have criticized this as creators
ryan murphy and brad falchuk's poking
fun at the fandom by purposely creating
an annoying whiny brat as their
representation of the fandom and i kind
of get it i've done videos rewriting the
endings of both apocalypse and 1984
because i didn't like them but what i
think they miss here is that it comes
from a place of love i love the show so
much regardless it's always dangerous
when you bite the hand that feeds i want
to hear what you guys thought about this
in the comments below moving on we meet
these three new girls who were killed 10
years ago by the rubber man and piggy
man even after ben harmon warned them
they should go and dylan mcdermott who
plays dr harmon is the biggest cameo we
get in this episode he having played dr
ben harmon in season 1 reprised it in
season 8 was season 2's johnny morgan
and was last seen as another killer
bruce in 1984. but for those keen eyed
viewers out there you'll notice some
inconsistencies starting to form number
one piggy man never actually was a
character that died in murder house he
was a figment of one of ben harmon's
patience derek number two if the murders
of these three women happened 10 years
ago how is ruby here she only became a
ghost of murder house in 2020. number
three just really really bad cgi blood
which most times ahs goes for the real
thing with some exceptions thankfully
these inconsistencies are rectified when
we learn everything we've been watching
in this introductory segment is part of
a video game hence the title game over
the infantada another character from
season one who is pieced together using
the remains of charles and norah
montgomery's dead child slashes dylan
and connie as they make their escape we
get more fan service with adelaide
langdon returning saying i told you dumb
[ __ ] you're gonna die in here yet
another inconsistency since adelaide
died off of the property in season 1 and
thus would never have returned as a
ghost budget twisty is here too along
with bloodyface and as far as we know
both of these two have never set foot on
murder house but as we know this is all
a video game made up by a woman named
michelle who is testing it on her son
rory the actor who plays rory played rob
kardashian in another ryan murphy show
american crime story rory is upset that
her mother doesn't get the show and if
she's going to make a video game on it
she should probably watch it i mean she
did mortgage the house and made this
game in a desperate attempt to please
him when he's like uh mom you could have
just asked me to watch the show with you
so rory gets up and goes to live with
his dad for a bit because he needs some
time away from his mom time michelle
uses to binge the show and actually go
buy murder house for the low low price
of a hundred thousand dollars you know
maybe she doesn't have money problems
anymore so michelle lies to her son
saying she's going off to a convention
to ask the ahs writer some questions
about the house her ex-husband says of
her and if you've got one fatal flaw
it's that you're so convinced that
you've got something to prove that you
will kill yourself to prove it well she
does end up dead over her murder house
obsession michelle arrives at her new
home totally not concerned a parade of
ghosts are exiting her home a particular
note is the pesticide dude aptly named
phil critter from season 1. he was hired
by ben to get rid of blowflies but ended
up discovering the body of violent and
was subsequently killed by tate who made
him ingest his own poisons the other
notable ghosts are the four girls who
pranked scarlet from episodes one and
two of this season we'll see scarlett
here with ruby who visits her every
halloween the one night of the year
where the ghosts are free to roam
outside of murder house so of course the
two spend that time in the home michelle
searches the empty house likely empty
because all the ghosts are roaming the
world and finds ben harmon crying i
usually only cry like this after i
masturbate which is what he did in
season one it's kind of funny she
doesn't immediately recognize him as ben
harmon after just binge watching the
entire season ben tells her that murder
house is hell he's stuck here blaming
others and not himself he mentions
hayden the woman he had an affair with
from season one played by kate mara he
says he's even talked to another
therapist about his problems referring
to episode 1's dr andy grant who was
later killed michelle says the people
who are trapped here are probably stuck
because they never resolved their issues
when they were alive but as ruby tells
her some ghosts don't want to leave they
just want to see others suffer michelle
ends up being killed by the rubber woman
which scarlett is dressed up as a year
later on halloween the ghost of michelle
visits her son who is once again pissed
off at her still harboring resentment
that she lied about where she was going
last halloween and buying murder house
he mentions that her only way to escape
is through fire but if he burns the
house down she'll be gone forever and
that's what he'll end up doing on the
morning after halloween the ghosts are
brought back to murder house and here we
can see one of the girls spending her
last moments with her brother who we
also saw in episode 2 of this season i
don't think we've ever seen this before
but correct me if i'm wrong once the sun
rises if a ghost is not in murder house
they are transported back which is what
we see happen here with ruby nonetheless
this is a moot point as we'll find out
this is all a video game but we'll get
to that in a bit rory comes down the
street rolling a wheelbarrow filled to
the brim with canisters of gasoline
which is just hilarious and michelle
watches as we get a very brief cameo of
the therapist from episode 1. ruby wants
to stomp and kill rory when ben and the
girls put an end to her allowing rory
enough time to light the building on
fire as it burns ruby asks scarlett to
quote die with her but scarlett walks
away we also hear tate langdon's
whistling tune here from season 1 as the
building goes up in flames three years
later and scarlett is with tim the
realtor the same guy who sold murder
house to michelle murder house has been
transformed into condos and according to
tim none of the new tenants have seen
any apparitions or have been harmed the
fire must have purified the occult
forces just like rory had said scarlett
ends up buying the last unit for 1
million dollars and even jokes to the
realtor she earned her money from being
a hitman we did see her kill ruby's
uncle tony in episode 2. she unpacks a
framed butterfly i discussed how this
signified transformation in my episode 1
and 2 breakdown this time it is the
house that has literally transformed we
also see one of her dolls that she
unpacked in episode 1. scarlett has
purchased the apartment in the hopes of
reuniting with ruby which she does when
ruby appears to her in bed dressed as
the rubber woman ruby tells her the
others have moved on and she's the only
one who has stayed scarlett tells her
the cheesy line that true love never
dies as we get bloody fireworks
congratulating us for beating the game
yes this was all a game rory tells
michelle she's finally got the vibe of
the show in this new version and even
quips that there should be a level where
you need to get a potion from the coven
witches in order to burn the place down
yet another meta commentary on fans
dictating how the show should be written
for those wondering where reality starts
and ends in this episode it's fair to
assume that everything after rory leaves
to chill with his dad and that intro
with connie and dylan never happen so
michelle buying the house getting killed
and rory burning it down never occurred
that only happened in the video game
this implies that murder house is still
alive and well and that none of the
events that occurred in this house in
this episode are ahs canon we do however
get a curveball quite literally with
bo's red ball showing up at the end this
could mean two things one that michelle
simply had it as a prop in her research
for murder house we do see her here with
posters of ahs characters or it could
mean that the video game has allowed the
ghost to somehow venture out of murder
house through the video game similar to
how in episode 3's drive-in the movie
rabbit rabbit was able to infiltrate
people's homes and psyches i might do a
separate video on my thoughts about hs
stories with the season 2 i really hope
they take some of the lessons they've
learned here and make a marked
improvement remember that hs double
feature comes out on the 25th and
consider subscribing as i'll be breaking
down every episode let me know what you
thought about american horror stories in
the comments below thanks for watching
for more bad takes you can always follow
me on twitter and instagram at
thingstoryt until next time remember
daddy loves you very much
you